Voiceover: A cyclist starts pedaling
and accelerates for 12 seconds.
The velocity v of t of the cyclist at
two second intervals in feet per
second is given by the table.
So they tell us at different times.
After four seconds the velocity
is 7.5 feet per second.
After eight seconds the velocity
is nine feet per second.
Consider the graph of
velocity versus time.
Velocity versus time.
Let capital r of six be
the sum of the areas of
six right hand rectangles
with equal sub-divisions.
It follows that capital r of six is
an approximation for the total distance
traveled in feet during the 12 seconds.
What is the value of capital r of six?
I encourage you to pause this video
and try to think about it on your own
and then I'll work through it and at any
time while I'm working through it, if you
get inspired, feel free to pause again
and try to take it all the way.
Let's think about what they're saying.
They say "consider the graph
of velocity versus time."
We might as well try to plot that.
I've got some graph paper here and we can
focus on the first quadrant because all of
our time values and all of our
velocity values are positive.
Let's see this is time, this is velocity
as a function of time axis, time goes
between zero and 12 and they're giving
it to us in every two seconds.
So, this is zero, two, four, six, eight,
ten and 12 seconds, and then our velocity
goes between zero and ten feet per second.
So, this is one, two, three, four, five,
I'll just mark off some of them.
Six, seven, eight, nine, ten.
Now, this is in feet per second
and this over here is in seconds.
Let's plot these points at time zero,
velocity is zero.
Time two velocity is six feet per second.
Time four at 7.5 gets us right there.
Time six it's 8.5, that 8, 8.5.
Time eight at eight seconds
it's nine feet per second.
At ten seconds it's 9.5 feet per second,
and at 12 seconds it's ten feet,
it's ten feet per second.
What I've done here is I've just plotted
the data that they've
given us, considering
the graph of velocity
versus time, at least
the data they've given us.
We can imagine fitting a curve
that looks something like this.
If we were to, these
points are just sampled
from a curve, they might
look something like,
something like this, over there.
We are now considering the graph
of velocity versus time.
Now let's think about the sum of the areas
of six right handed rectangles
with equal sub-divisions.
When they're talking
about equal sub-divisions,
they're talking about equal sub-divisions
along the independent
axis or the time axis
in this case and we're
talking about the first
12 seconds, so if we
were to divide the first
12 seconds into six equal
sections, they would
each be 2 seconds wide.
This would be one of them.
Let me do this in a new color.
They would each be 2 seconds.
That's not a new color, oh it is, blue.
They're each going to be two seconds.
Let me do one that
contrasts with green better.
Each of our rectangles are going to be two
seconds wide and I'm just kind of starting
them off at the bottom because we have
to think about how tall to make them.
Then they say to do
right handed rectangles.
What's a right handed rectangle?
That means we define the height of
the rectangle by the value of
the function on the right hand side.
So, for example this first rectangle,
to make it a right handed
rectangle, we look at
the right side, we're
at two seconds, velocity
at two seconds is six feet per second
and so that's going to be
the height of our rectangle.
This next one is going to look like this.
Now you might say "Well, what's a left
handed rectangle then?"
Well, a left handed
rectangle would be doing
something like, would be
doing something like...
Okay, for this first rectangle on the left
hand side of it, my function is zero.
So, it's just zero.
Now the next rectangle,
the left hand side,
my function at two seconds,
the function is six seconds.
So, the left hand rectangles would look
like this, would look something like that.
But anyway they're telling us to do right
handed rectangles so let's do
right handed rectangles.
Let me clear this a little bit.
This is our first right handed rectangle.
This is our second one.
Let me just draw the tops.
Third, fourth, fifth and sixth that was
the tops of them.
It's just going to look
something like this.
It's going to look like this.
This is my third one.
That's my fourth one.
That's my fifth one.
Then, that's my sixth one.
They're tell us let capital r of six
be the sum of the areas of these things
and they tell us that it follows that
capital r of six is an approximation for
the total distance traveled
in feet during the 12 seconds.
Now why is that?
Why is the sum of these
areas an approximation
for the total distance traveled?
Well before calculus, you learned,
that if you have a constant rate,
that distance is equal to rate times time.
Once again, this is assuming,
that assumes a constant rate.
Our rate in this example
is clearly changing.
We are clearly accelerating
right over here
but maybe we can approximate the distance
traveled if we assume a constant rate over
an interval, say over
two second intervals.
Then we just, we try to roughly, when
we assume some velocity
over that interval.
When we take these
right handed rectangles,
let's just focus on this first rectangle.
If I'm taking the area of this
first rectangle, what am I doing?
I'm multiplying it's
height times it's width.
It's height is going to be the velocity
at the end of two seconds and
it's width is the two seconds.
If I were to multiply six feet
per second times two seconds.
That will get me 12 feet,
let me make that very clear.
The area for that one area is equal to six
feet per second, my
velocity, it's actually
the speed but we're not going to get
particular about whether we're
getting the direction as well.
Six feet per second times two seconds.
That's going to get me 12 feet.
That we can say is an
approximation because
we're saying "Okay, you
trialed at two seconds
"at some velocity" but is that going
to be an overestimate or an underestimate?
It's going to be an overestimate because
you're taking the fastest velocity
over the interval.
The interval started with the cyclist
going zero feet per second.
It's clearly overestimating
and if you think
about it and I encourage you to pause
the video and think about it on your own.
If we did a left handed rectangle it would
be underestimating it because we would
be taking the slowest
velocity over the interval
and multiplying it by the interval.
This is an approximation.
Let's just calculate what r of six is.
R of six is going to be the area of
this rectangle which, as we just said,
it's six feet per second times two seconds
so it's going to be 12
feet and then we have
this rectangle which
is going to be 7.5 feet
per second times two
seconds which is going
to be 15 feet, 15 feet
and you can even see
it in the area right over here.
It's going to be three feet more.
One, two and then half of two of these to
it's going to be three feet more and then
the area of this one which is going to be
8.5, so our velocity at the end of
the interval is going to be 8.5 feet per
seconds times two seconds which is 17 feet
and then plus this area
which is our velocity
at the end of the interval which is nine
feet per second times two seconds so plus
18 and then we get the
velocity of this area
which is going to be this height.
The velocity at the end of the interval
which is 9.5 feet per second
times two seconds so, plus 19.
Then finally this area
which is the velocity
at the end of the
interval which is ten feet
per second times two seconds so, plus 20.
What does this give us?
This is the point of which I'm most likely
going to make an error.
12 plus 15 is 27 and then 27 plus 10 is 37
plus another seven is
44, so that gives us 44.
44 plus 18 is going to give me, let's see,
I can get to 52 and then
62, so this is going
to be 62 plus 19 is 81, plus 20 is 101,
that's going to be in feet.
Capital r of six, 101 feet, it is an
approximation for the total distance
traveled during the 12 seconds but
it's really an over approximation because
for every interval, we're taking
the fastest velocity of the interval.
If we took the slowest
velocity of the interval
in would be an underestimate.
If we did left handed
rectangles and we might
have gotten something in between if we say
maybe took the average of these too.
If we made the height of the rectangle
three for this first one
or something like that.
We'll do that in the
future, in future videos.